all right Dasha
Dasha where are you from where'd you
grow up um I was born and raised in
Ukraine Ukraine
tell me about your family growing up you
had Mom and Dad
um yeah I was very
fortunate to have a really beautiful
life in Ukraine
um I was really bitter when I had to
immigrate
um what age
uh six seven around there
um but yeah I
got to see almost my entire family like
almost weekly if not daily
um they all played a really huge
you know part in raising me I was born
in a village
um we were the only Village the only
house in the village who that had a cow
so you know we had a lot of people kind
of coming in and out and
um you know buying vegetables from us
and
um yeah it was a really like we were
very poor but it was a really rich life
I was just really lucky to have a lot of
love around me
um and
it kind of changed when I moved to the
states
[Music]
I you know I still had my parents but I
felt a little lonelier because I didn't
have my whole extended family which I
was just really attached to
um and I still am
um and obviously given like what's
happening in the country right now it
makes it
even more difficult
um
which is uh something I don't really
talk a lot about I like to
you know I like to shed Awareness on
things that are going on but I never
really talk about what's happening in my
family
um how bad is it for them it's um it's
not great we we lost someone
um
you know it's really close to home for
me
um
my
I have two family members who are in the
Army
um
and my cousin's husband is one of them
and he got hit by a Russian missile
um
it's been about a year since he's been
gone
um
yeah this isn't something that's it
wasn't surprising to us my my
grandmothers survived two famines
um
you know because of all of this it's
kind of
in the history of being Ukrainian is
kind of fighting fighting them off
unfortunately
um
but
yeah I mean I get I get to talk to my
family somewhat often I think sometimes
I feel a little
a little bad because I don't talk to
them as much as I'd like to because I
have to spend the whole day recuperating
from talking to them because it it hurts
um
and it's not like
it's not like a normal traumatic event
where something happens you have to move
on and process our trauma it's just
something that like you have to live
with every single day and
you know have to keep doing everything
else and I'm relatively a very happy
person
um so it just randomly something will
remind me of it and then I get sad and
then you just have to keep you just have
to move on forget about it distract
yourself yeah it's in the news all the
time it is
um I remember got to one point where I
had to tell my gym like can you please
stop playing this like it's like every
morning like but I don't want to start
my morning like this like I like to
start my morning in the gym because I
want to you know have a good start to
the day
um and having to see that is like really
frustrating especially when I'm looking
at people around me like
it's not affecting everyone else the way
it affects me
so I I don't really like to watch it and
um my cousin promised well he wanted me
to promise him that I wouldn't just like
fixate on the news all the time so
I
I've decided not to because yeah like
there's a lot of misinformation or some
things that are true and you just don't
know what's what and um I think you just
don't want to believe some of it as well
um
so it's obviously very difficult
um and I've always been very patriotic
like well before this like anytime
someone's like oh are you are you
Russian I don't like no I'm Ukrainian
um well before this I've always been
really proud to be
Ukrainian
um
so yeah it was just it was a really
beautiful life so I'm definitely bitter
for sure are you grateful to be in the
United States I am of course I mean I
love my life here I've built a really
beautiful life obviously it's very
unconventional
um but I'm very proud of it
um how did you get introduced to this
doing sex work like this so
I think it started with
me finding a passion in sex education
when I entered High School I realized
just how bad sex education is in the
country and honestly all over the world
and it made me very angry
and it made me want to study psychology
more than anything
and so
um
I moved to London and I studied
psychology there and almost immediately
like I wanted to go into sex therapy
that's thought that's that was the
initial plan
um but I started getting curious
and um
almost immediately after I moved there I
started
like exploring
um the whole scene before I even before
I even moved I was really inspired by
different sex workers I would follow on
the internet and I think the one thing
that Drew me to it more than anything
was the sense of community like sex
workers are very
very United
um but at the same time like they don't
stand behind people that
they find problematic or bad
um
so I just found it just really resonated
with me
um I think the people more than anything
and still to this day like all the
people I looked up to are now some of my
closest friends and I'm
um I'm very proud of that
um but yeah I started um kind of
exploring sugar babying first
um which I think you know a lot of
people are curious about
um and unfortunately I do think it's a
gateway to sex work
um but I started exploring that and I
think after a while you
get really entranced
by
the appeal of making someone
feel good and the attention and then
also you know getting rewarded for it
um so is there something about your
personality your childhood the way you
were raised
that made this I I do think about that
and every single
woman in my family is really strong and
they're all slightly sadistic for sure
um and I've always loved that but like
in the most nurturing way
um and I consider myself to be a mommy
Dom
um which is just a style of domination
yeah it's a style of domination
um I don't consider it particularly to
be a role play like like some might
think
um but I would consider it to be someone
who is dominant nurturing maybe even a
little coercive
um it's it's a really fun Dynamic
um
and I've just always considered that to
be me because I love being able to like
mix Pleasure and Pain
um all different psychology comes I know
and it goes hand in hand with what you
do doesn't it it does
um and so many dominatrixes that I've
met studied psychology and um I think
someone needs to do a study on that
because it's quite it's quite
fascinating
what is it about the the makeup of men
that
they need to have somebody
I think are you are you abusive to them
at times I I wouldn't say I'm abusive I
mean I think a lot of the times I
provide structure for some of these
people
um more than anything
um why I continue to do what I do
um is it so rewarding to see
to just to see someone feel
really validated because a lot of the
times
I think femdoms and submissives are told
that they're not allowed to act in this
way and when you have someone that you
know allows you to
explore this in a in a healthy way and
that's not abusive
um it just it feels
like a catharsis for a lot of people
because a lot of the times what I'm
exploring more than anything because
most of the people that I've I've seen
they're not engaging in extreme BDSM or
you know anything very hardcore it's
just at the root of it like people want
to experience role reversal and men in
particular
they like the idea of feeling desired of
feeling pretty and I think we just don't
allow men to feel that way and I also
think we don't allow women to always
feel powerful
and so
I feel like I'm able to give people that
outlet and for me that just it means the
world
um and I also think
that I've had a lot of women who've come
to me who've experienced
you know bad Doms for example who have
hurt their relationship with BDSM
and they'll come to me
because they haven't given up on the
journey
but um
they
they want to be able to heal their
relationship with BDSM which I think is
um
really beautiful and I'm I love being
able to provide that for people
um
so give me give me an example of
a particularly interesting interaction
that you'll have with one of your
clients
sure
um so a lot of the times when I before I
even see them I will talk to them about
um
like The Kinks that they're interested
in exploring with me in particular
and also the feelings that they want to
achieve so
recently I saw someone who the whole
goal was just
to want to feel desired and out and
um
that is exactly what I attempted to to
do
um and I think with that is where like
my sensuality kind of comes in because
especially when you have someone pretty
who
um like really shows you that they want
you
um it's very validating obviously
um and I think that's something that I
bring to this is like a lot of
authenticity
um you enjoy this I do so much
um and I never really understand people
who you know hate on what I do
um
because I'm just so happy well it's a
form of
therapy isn't it
um it really is and
especially if I have let me let me ask
you a Frank question are are you having
sex with your clients
um I am not yeah see that's why I
suspected yeah and so really what you're
doing is therapy with maybe some Spandex
and some I mean latex and uh and some
whips and some boots and stuff like that
yeah yeah it's um
it's it's really beautiful
um I did at one point used to do like
some independent escorting and everyone
would always want me to Dom
so I've always had a very dominant
personality everyone's always said that
from when I was little everyone's like
Dasha is the most confident person that
I've ever met so like a lot of this like
in retrospect makes sense
um but
yeah I just I've I've also like offered
it at times to clients they're always
like no thanks and this is
natural for you your personality yeah
yeah this is not an act you're putting
on yes and I think it's very hard to
fake being a good Dom
um I think there are other parts of us
like sex work that you can you know kind
of put on a role and kind of clock and
clock out
um but this is one of those things that
one like you have to be present 24 7
because if you are disassociating at any
point like the scene's not moving along
because you are
you are everything in this role like you
are taking control you are taking
responsibility for any risks that are
going to happen so you need to be very
very present I think it's also kind of
important not to
um you know have a huge volume of
clients because you need to be so
um so present I mean for example if I
have a if I have a session with a couple
in particular
um most of the times I sleep for like 12
hours and I am so exhausted I feel
very euphoric for sure
um you get this like top High
um and I love being a top for sure
um
but yeah it's just
it's it's a lot and after you're done
it's just like okay I can't do anything
else but relax for the rest of the day
and
um resting is a really big part of sex
work doesn't matter what you know area
or aspect of sex worker that you're
involved in like you really need to make
sure that you're taking care of your
body because
um it's very taxing at times for sure
are drugs a part of your life at all no
so I'm I'm actually like one of the like
healthiest people that anyone knows I'm
um
I've been vegan for like eight years I
um I don't drink at all I don't do any
drugs
um you know I come from a Ukrainian
family so drinking was really you know
you don't need to apologize for being
clean I know I do
um but yeah I just like my family was
always fine if I drank
um and I think that's what kept me from
doing it like my parents have always
been really supportive like for example
they don't love that I do this but
um they're always very very supportive
um and they like to like joke around
about it and
um I just find it very easy and also I
think everyone in my life knows that
like
I'm the type of person that like I am
very easy to cut someone off if I feel
like they are not accepting what I do
because I am just very stubborn in that
way
um just like the rest of my family so
um they just they know that they have to
be accepting of it because I will always
do what I want and a lot of the times
I'm I I know how to take care of myself
do you have a lot of regulars
um I do thankfully
um I think I attract more than anything
a lot of international clients
um because of the fact that I'm an
immigrant
um and I have you know
um lived in multiple countries
um so it's really interesting but I have
regulars who don't even live in New York
um and who will you know they might have
work here and then they try to make sure
that they see me while they're while
they're here
um and then also some locals which is
great as well
um
but nothing actually happier than
couples I love working with couples
because the dynamic is just so unique
um and every relationship is so
different whereas like with individuals
you can kind of
expect more what are you learning about
relationships and men from doing this
um I think more than anything that
like specifically relationships I mean
it's very difficult for me
to date now because I have such a higher
standard because obviously being a Dom a
lot of my clients worship me and
obviously that's very validating
um and you know they they bring me
presents they are just I'm so lucky I
think I have some of the best clients
actually but I think that also comes
down to my vetting process
um but it is being worshiped something
that you would
want in a romantic relationship it is it
is okay and this is what makes
relationships interesting because
they're all different kinds I exactly
um there's so many different ways to
obviously approach a relationship and I
think a lot of the times I don't
approach it very conventionally given
what I do
um and I also
um I'm also a content creator so I'm you
know having sex on camera with other
people
um most of the time I'm topping but
um you know I can't be in a conventional
relationship nor would I
nor do I have the desire to be in that
have you had
a regular conventional relationship
before no I haven't
um how old are you I um I'm 22. I just
turned 22. well you're young so I know I
know I have a lot of time which is uh
I think about a lot because
I've already done so much and I'm always
like what's left and
um somehow I find the next thing but
like I just recently bought a house
um I'm very proud of that
um so the money you're making is good
yes thankfully
um and I think you know there's a
privilege with being able to say
no to certain clients especially like
people that you don't feel comfortable
working with and I do really have to
thank my content creation because it
supplements a decent chunk of my income
as well
um so I'm very is that only chance yeah
only fans and other subscription
platforms and
um yeah like Club sites things like that
how do you
compare what you do to let's say a
typical street prostitute who is kind of
doing the same thing you're doing but
probably making sounds like less money
not saving it doing a lot more dangerous
stuff yeah
um well so you seem to have found the
like the top Echelon of yeah I mean I'm
very lucky because
um I had a lot of people be like oh I
think you'd be really great online like
a lot of my friends
um because I have the personality for it
um and I immediately started going on
like Tick Tock and gaining a presence
there and I got big very quickly
um and people liked my personality they
enjoyed the whole mommy Dom aspect
um which is very trendy at the moment as
well
um and so it worked really well to be
able to you know recruit subscribers and
such and occasionally clients
um but I was just very fortunate for
that because I thankfully have a
business mind like I I know how to
Market I know how to I pick up skills
very well and very quickly so you know I
run my entire business top to bottom by
myself I've tried to hire people but
obviously I'm a control freak
um so yeah I've just I've learned so
much from the fact that like I just I do
everything A to Z from the marketing
thinking of Concepts editing directing
like absolutely everything
um so it's it's a lot but not everyone
has the mindset for it and I've talked
to a lot of different sex workers and
some people just get into the industry
simply because they like sex or they
like BDSM
um and they don't particularly love the
business side as much which is
understandable
and there's also a lot of people in this
industry we have a lot of you know
marginalized communities like a large
community of disabled workers
um you know people of color
Etc who just um
in general
obviously like I'm privileged to be
pretty and
um
it just obviously makes it easier like
going viral was very easy for me when I
initially started algorithms are
constantly changing but
I think I can't entirely talk about the
life of
someone working on the street but
survival sex work is a very
different
much more dangerous obviously yeah much
more dangerous and I think that comes
back to the fact that no but like you're
buying a house yes and a lot of the sex
workers I've worked that are doing a
more dangerous type of work yeah they're
not buying houses no of course they
don't own cars they don't even have an
apartment no I know and that's um
yeah no I mean I think about that all
the time because and you're not even
having sex in most cases yeah yeah
um obviously there's so many aspects of
sex work and there's a lot of it that is
dangerous and I obviously seeing
in-person clients like you're exposing
yourself to danger and being online as
well just there's there's a big stigma
that comes with doing what we do
um what do your parents think of it
um like I said they're very supportive
um again they don't love the idea of
what I do but my dad is gonna love his
daughter's doing this oh it's kind
because my dad makes jokes more than
more than anyone about it and he finds
it funny
um
and also I think my parents like they
they get it they've always been very
um like they've never shamed me about my
sexuality
um and I could just tell that they've
always been very open
um and probably not approaching sex the
same way that other people do
um and I've always been really thankful
for that because
I mean you know you hear about so many
people who are very sexually repressed
because Americans tend to be pretty
uptight they do sexually are Europeans
the same way are you Russians ukrainians
definitely not
um you know for example like I feel like
I can if I'm having an issue with
something like I can go to my mom and be
able to talk about it and um I'm really
thankful for that like I'm very close to
my parents I talk to them multiple times
a day
um I do really love like getting their
opinion on certain things it's obviously
not in a
unhealthy way like I would never come to
them with something with something weird
but
um it's it's really nice to be able to
have like an open dialogue and be able
to trust my parents and um yeah I'm very
lucky for that I mean I know not
everyone has that especially in sex work
I feel like a lot of people feel like
they they need to hide what they do
um but my parents have always known that
like if you if you want to be in my life
you have to accept me fully
um and my mom said that from birth she's
like she's gonna do what she wants she
goes I cannot control her
um but thankfully like I have found
the best path I think I could take for
myself at 22. yeah yeah
um and I know I'm much younger than I
think a lot of people think that I am
um and especially because like it's been
a really
it's been a long four years like I feel
like I've accomplished so much within
that time
um but yeah I think also they just there
comes a security with doing online sex
work more than anything and I think a
lot of us get really terrified when we
see
um you know sex work abolitionists and
payment processors try to kind of shut
down what we're doing because all you do
would be sending the people who have
found this Safe Haven pushing at us us
out onto the streets making the world
more dangerous 100 and
um that's also something I'm very very
passionate about because I think sex
work of all sorts of most sorts should
be uh legalized I do I do I think it's
really important to decriminalize sex
work and I think it's also really
important to consult sex workers when
you know making any kind of legislation
because when you look back to like false
assessor for example you know they have
basically turned any kind of media we
consume it doesn't matter if you are
engaging in consensual sex work they
still consider it
um like soliciting or part of sex
trafficking and it's
it's just really terrifying to see that
um and it I think people don't realize
how much that it goes into the
censorship of our media because it goes
as far as taking down a girl's post just
because you see the outline of her
nipple through a shirt because anything
remotely sexual
like social media platforms don't want
to be seen as aiding and enabling you
have to tell me is that traffic yeah you
don't have to talk I'm sure yeah I mean
anyone who's in who's in I mean does
this will get demonetized for what's
underneath your chin there yeah I mean
it's obviously very difficult because
anyone who
um has a smaller chest than me a lot of
the times can get away with some of
those things compared to me just because
I have the chest that I have which you
know causing me a lot of back pain I
mean I I didn't choose this you show a
female nipple and it'll get me in
trouble but a male nipple is fine
exactly and that's obviously so
frustrating and it doesn't make any
sense to me and it never has
um but yeah it just I think people don't
really realize how
how
you know how the span of it and how it
goes across the entire internet from
actual sex workers and trying to keep us
from doing what we do but also all the
way to just policing women's bodies yeah
no religion complicates it yes a lot of
things
complicated but it's it's a mess it is a
mess and obviously we have everyone from
sex work abolitionist to Evangelical
Christians all of them lobbying or
pretending like they're not sexual
exactly and it just doesn't make sense
because again because I'm European I
think we really value women and our
sexuality more than
more than I think other parts of the
world and we I mean we celebrate women
at the end of the day I mean and I just
I really appreciate that like
we definitely have a very strong
matriarch in the family and like that's
how it's always been
um from my grandmother to my mother like
it's just always been that way we
we put women on a pedestal and
I just I don't understand how we can
pretend like we're not all having sex
and that you know sex doesn't create us
put us onto the world and
um like I said I'm very passionate about
sex education because you know we can't
just like leave it up to the parents all
of the time because especially if you're
having parents who are like no we can't
talk about that like sex is evil sex is
bad like don't have that until you get
married it's like that's when you end up
with people in dangerous situations and
because they just weren't properly
educated they don't understand
contraception they get coerced into bad
situations like that's that's terrible
yeah
so back back to your work and your
clients The Stereotype is that your
clients are
powerful businessmen that are older than
you yeah quite a bit older I mean um
one thing I can say about submissives is
I don't think there's a demographic you
can't just be like it's not a it's not a
man who's got a powerful position at
work yeah and he needs to order that
somehow of course sex work is a luxury
um you know most of us aren't you know
cheap especially if you are wanting to
see someone regularly like you have to
have the income to be able to sustain
that
um
but at the same time I mean I've had
some people who they make less but they
really want to be able to explore this
part of themselves
because I think it's also very just easy
to stumble upon
BDSM porn and
find you know some interest in that I
mean I think at the end of the day
anything can make us aroused
and so they get curious and something
sparked their interest and
nothing makes me happier than seeing
someone who's never done this before and
go to a professional
because it's just it's so much better
than just fumbling around with someone
who doesn't know what they're doing
especially because there are aspects of
BDSM that are dangerous and as a Dom I'm
taking on responsibility and making sure
that I am you know prioritizing my
safety and also their safety
um and if you're seeing someone who
hasn't done this before and was also
like hey I watched this video like can
we kind of do that and the other person
has no idea what they're doing
um especially because
I I will always stand by this but like
the best porn is always behind a paywall
because anything that is important most
of the time it is being actually it's
actually advertising for someone else's
content
um like long form content
um so it's really you know you're just
getting bits and pieces and a lot of the
times you're getting this like gimmicky
kind of BDSM stuff it's not very natural
it's not very authentic
um and there are definitely people who
want that those are not my clients I
prefer to see people who you know really
enjoy the lifestyle and maybe can't
engage in it 24 7 or some people who do
engage in a 24 7 but particularly like
my style of domination and that's why
they they choose to see me over
someone else but yeah it just makes me
so happy to see someone who's not done
this before and choose to see a
professional because I think it's just
it sets you up to have one of the best
experiences that you could as an initial
like introduction into BDSM
so again that's very rewarding for me to
be able communication is a huge
component in all this it's huge I mean
whenever I have for example if I have a
client and we are on the phone
um talking about all of these things
like what we want to engage in and they
can't properly communicate to me like
what they want
um I won't see them like I'm not
interested in someone who's like oh you
do what you want because that is
something that I can take the lead on
with someone that I've known for a while
and I understand their limits very well
I understand their interests very well
and I understand maybe some of those
soft limits that I can push a little bit
um and you know maybe get them
introduced into some
other Kinks that are adjacent to their
other Kinks because you because you have
a prior relationship with them exactly
but if I've never met them before
um I think we can never assume that
someone is into
um like certain echelons like for
example if someone tells me they're into
med fit like which is medical fetish you
think that that is something fairly
extreme but for example that person
might not be into let's say bondage
which for a lot of people might seem as
something kind of beginner again you
just you can't assume that there are
like tears
um because everyone has different
triggers everyone has different
experiences especially if you had prior
experiences in BDSM with someone who
didn't know what they're doing
um like I just don't know what they did
that might have set off that person and
makes them uncomfortable and that
immediately takes them out of Subspace
which is just
the worst thing I think that can happen
in a session
um but it's just so so so important to
be communicative because if you leave
something out and I happen to do that
like I want to immediately go into
Aftercare
um and if they're not communicating that
like I won't know that and the last
thing you want is to traumatize a client
like I mean that's
that's just terrifying what advice can
you give to women about their
relationships with with men
um sexual or otherwise yeah I think it's
really important to
find what makes you confident and just
not sacrifice that whenever you are in a
relationship because I think sometimes
people settle or they
compromise and I think that they're just
certain things in your life that you
cannot compromise on and yeah it's
difficult because they're obviously
within my within my industry like I'm
dealing with a lot of people who do
objectify me
um
but you just need to be able to
pick out
who is and who isn't and who's authentic
and at the end of the day I understand
that I am a pretty woman
but also like
I'm providing the service that I think
is really invaluable to a lot of people
and I think if someone doesn't see the
value in that then you know I wouldn't
want to be able I wouldn't want to see
them so I think for any any woman who is
interested in exploring their dominance
and their power like I think it's a
really
wonderful thing to explore whether or
not that's something you do on a regular
basis or you get into this
as a lifestyle like I do obviously this
is an extreme but
you know I find so much happiness in it
and I know that there are a ton of other
women who
um might be a little bit nervous about
engaging in it especially when we live
in a society that doesn't exactly reward
us for being
powerful and being able to express our
confidence in the way that I do so
is some of what your makeup is is from
the fact that women are tend to play a
submissive role
um in society I think so I I think I've
always been somewhat of a rebel and so
when I started seeing people viewing me
as submissive like I just immediately
went the opposite direction because I
was like that is not me and no one has
ever described me as that and I think a
lot of people tend to put their
fantasies on to people
um without really understanding
what that other person is like or into
so yeah I think a lot of it came from
the fact that women are supposed to be
submissive so I was like that's not me
um and like I don't consider myself to
be a switch like I am very much dominant
both in like lifestyle practice and
professionally
um although I do engage in like some
vanilla acts as well
um because we're all human and enjoy sex
but
it's interesting how there's so many
little sub groups in in sex I know and I
think about that all the time because on
my channel you can see about 30 of them
exactly yeah and something that I like
to do is I like to be able to explore
BDSM as a dominant and maybe introduce
some things that some particular Kinks
or acts that might be seen as submissive
and do it in a dominant way and just get
people to really
reevaluate their reevalue their
relationship with sexuality and BDSM and
be like oh okay you can actually apply
that in any way at the end of the day
it's about the dynamic not about that
particular Kink you're engaging in right
like you don't have to put someone on a
collar and Leash and like just call it
BDSM right like you could just there's
so much you can do
um and it's really fun to explore those
Dynamics I'm sure there's clients of
yours that don't want sex at all yeah
like I said I've I've tried to offer it
multiple times
um to people that I'm comfortable with
and they're like no thanks
um
so I find that
um kind of amusing
um they just really enjoy the dynamic
that I offer and whenever they think
about that like sometimes it's almost
like I don't even want to think about
you in that context they're like I just
want to see you as this person who is
above me and better than me
um which is obviously a really
interesting Dynamic oh it's fascinating
I know
um but majority of the times truly
submissive
um men in particular they
they really don't have an interest in it
like they are
so enamored by BDSM that that is just
the path that they wanted to that's all
they want yeah that's all they want
um and I think a lot of the times
something that I engage in particular is
like conditioning and getting people to
you know
get a certain reaction out of things
that I do and I love being able to do
that like I love being able to reward
people for certain acts and then
um you know punish them for other acts
um yeah I've definitely re-wired some
men's Brains
um but obviously consensually but what
do your female friends think of what you
do
um most of my friends are sex workers oh
is it right yeah most most of them
um anyone who's not
um is also very like sexually liberal
um whether they are submissive
themselves or not or just very vanilla
um I think particularly living in New
York like it's very common for people to
be really open about these things and
especially given the fact that I've
lived in London and New York like
BDSM is very common like people talk
about you hear people talking about it
on the street you hear people talking
about it you know at even a restaurant
at times
um this is something I'm very open about
and I think a lot of metropolitan cities
are as well
um or they're very kinky or they have a
kink scene right I mean if you go into
the middle of like not like New York
though yeah that's true New York City is
the best right New York City is the best
um I do really love it here but you know
if you go into some like rural town like
you know it's obviously going to be seen
as a lot more deviant
um and I'm very thankful to surround
myself around a lot of people who are
supportive and accepting of what I do
um and even as far as understand it
um because I think there's a lot of what
we do that people are just like I don't
really get it but okay you know
um and it's not for everyone and I don't
think BDSM should be mainstream and I
don't think people should be absolutely
not no of course not because that's when
you have you know like for example uh
high schoolers choking out partners and
things like that like that's that's
terrifying it should not be mainstream
at all
um that's where communication comes in
exactly
um and that's also something that we
really need to
educate anyone who's having sex or
um just engaging in anything remotely
sexual is just to communicate to your
partners like what you like what you
don't like what you can and can't do you
just you can't really assume anything
um and that's why I think also BDSM is
really important to me and the fact that
we have negotiation like we are able to
talk about what might happen during the
scene what your limits are what your
interests are what your kinks are prior
to engaging in a scene so I come as well
prepared as possible because I just
don't want to put someone in an
uncomfortable position like that would
just it would make me awful it made me
feel awful like and I really really
really care about my submissives
um and it's something that I don't know
if every Tom feels that way but like I
do really love them
um even the people who I don't see very
often I just I do really want the best
for them because this is obviously
something that is very deviant for the
majority of the population
so I want to be able to bring validation
to those people however I do believe in
King shaming so
like I think it's because they're into
it
no no not necessarily I just mean if
someone's engaging in something
unethical oh I see I am more than happy
to be like I don't even know what King
Shame is what is King Shame like shaming
someone for having a particular Kink
which I think a lot of the times
um like it's guised as this like oh we
don't you know like make fun of people
for what they like but I think if
someone is like being like Oh I'm into
bestiality like no we are going to shame
them for that that is not a good thing
to do oh I see
um because there's a lot of people who
are into particular Kinks but in reality
there's just something unethical
um and like I would never enable someone
to engage in something
um especially if it's hurting someone
else in a non-consensual way just like
obviously children animals can't consent
um but yeah I'm more than happy to hurt
someone consensually yeah
and Dasha what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
22 years in your four years of doing
this crazy stuff yeah um
important thing that I've learned is
um
to trust yourself and my gut
uh it's really never let me down and
thankfully I've never been in
dangerous situations within this
industry and I think that comes from
just trusting myself and my ability to
understand people which I think is hyper
aware compared to other people
um and I'm very thankful for that and I
trust myself wholeheartedly
um
and yeah like I always tell myself to
trust past Dasha like if for example I'm
wondering if I lock the door I'm like no
I did because I know that I trust myself
to like do all these things
um and so I just I always trust my gut
um and I think that a woman's intuition
is just like
a superpower yes it is yeah all right
Dasha thank you so much for sharing your
story very fascinating thank you